let's go next to let's go to rich from
illinois rich welcome
hi david hello
um so i was the top mod of donald on
reddit for years until just before it
was banned and with elon buying twitter
do you think that there will be a
general shift in policy
for the uh the tech places um towards
allowing things
like medical misinformation such as
ivermectin and what
vice's motherboard did yesterday with uh
tweeting out the misoprostol for
abortion pills
i wha what i didn't see the what's the
vice thing tell me about that
yeah so they uh tweeted out from their
motherboard account that misoprostol
which is a horse medicine
uh to treat ulcers for horses
can be used for
abortion pills oh i see that now yeah uh
okay so let's go step by step first i uh
i actually discussed this with coleman
hughes in an already recorded but not
yet released podcast episode with him i
actually don't think that elon musk
taking over twitter if it happens
remember it's still not been approved
and i think it may not be but we'll wait
and see
i don't think it's going to do anything
mind-blowing on on twitter per se i
think maybe some people will be unbanned
maybe not i don't know that he is widely
going to be involved in content
moderation so
i i'm kind of re i'm not making any big
judgments about what's going to change
on twitter let's first wait and see if
the the buyout actually happens and then
we'll kind of think about that part
um in terms of uh i mean listen i don't
know much about this misoprostol thing
but
i i also don't know whether this is an
approved off-label use or not i don't
know anything about it but let me just
say right now
all of this stuff should be subject to
the same scrutiny whether it's being
promoted by left or right i i think it
all should be subjected to the exact
same terms of service
okay
that's good now let me ask you so you
were you were a top moderator on the
donald which was widely considered one
of the most toxic enclaves of the
internet until it was banned are you a
trump guy
i am wow and so and and now what do you
think about like do you believe
ivermectin works to treat covid
i i don't know because i'm not a doctor
okay how would you determine do you do
you think advil works for headaches
i do and why do you think that not being
a doctor
it does for some people it does for it
doesn't for others ibuprofen works for
others better than advil does or
or you know other things
are the same thing
yeah yeah
uh aspirin that's what i mean okay but
so why do you not being a doctor why do
you feel so strongly about your
knowledge of ibuprofen and not ivor
mexico no no yeah that wasn't the uh the
kind of gist of what i was trying to get
at um the fact that people were getting
banned for mentioning
off-label use of ivermectin which is
approved drug for humans but it's not
even covered you agree that with that
right
all right well i don't know but like i
said i'm not a doctor so i don't pretend
to wait a second hold on a second see
the problem is
whenever i ask you a direct question you
say i don't know because i'm not a
doctor but you just asserted you you do
know that ivermectin is quote approved
for humans but isn't how do you know
that without being a doctor
well i know that ivermectin is approved
for humans because that that is actually
um documented so maybe instead of saying
i don't know i'm not a doctor you would
just say i don't know
okay yeah so
if i were to assert to you
that the way we figure out if a
medication works for a condition is to
do a randomized controlled trial would
you agree that that's a good way to
figure out whether a medication works
i do believe in science so i would agree
100 with that beautiful and
if i told you that there were two
randomized controlled trials which
looked at ivermectin for kovid and
neither showed that it did anything
would that be compelling if you were to
see those studies i know you haven't
seen them
but given that you've accepted the
randomized controlled trial if
randomized controlled trials said it
doesn't work for kovid would that
satisfy you
oh of course it would okay good all
right well those studies exist check out
my clips on them okay
okay all right uh you still like trump
well i was going to say this um iso
pro so thing is being out there and they
are being banned for it even though it's
not approved for use for on humans they
are not being banned you're saying no
yeah yeah they did not listen this is
the first i heard about it so i i'm not
trying to cop out like it
these claims should all be managed in
the same way but in terms of terms of
service you know we have to have the
same rules no matter whether it's
hydroxy or misoprostol or whatever i
just don't know anything about
misoprostol right now so i can't say
okay fair
yep all right thanks so much for the
call i appreciate it yeah thanks for
taking it no problem all right see guys
look at that what a conversation
we were able to do it
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below